hello and welcome to special edition of
the book club podcast i'm sam leith
literature of the spectator and this
week i'm joined on film as well as on
radio by professor francis fukuyama
whose new book is liberalism and its
discontents
um professor vicky i'm welcome
now
liberal is a word that as you
acknowledge new introduction means
something very different in say
tennessee than it does in muswell hill
um
what exactly are the parameters of what
you call classical liberalism that's the
subject of this book
uh sure it does have a very different
meaning in the united states than it
does in europe
my um
definition of it is closer to the
european one
liberalism in my view is a system that's
basically a limitation of power based on
a rule of law
and a constitutional framework that
limits the power of
executives it's based on a number of
philosophical presumptions uh it there's
an element of universalism because
liberals believe that all
human beings have a uh equal set of
rights that these need to be protected
by
uh governments uh in europe you know
liberal parties have been associated
with a kind of center-right position
that emphasizes property rights
uh and rule of law and that's an
important part of classical liberalism
but i would say that it doesn't really
dictate any set of economic policies so
that for example
scandinavia over the last couple of
generations has been governed by social
democratic parties that do a lot of
redistribution but i would regard these
all as liberal parties essentially
because they all respect basic
individual rights
they tax at a higher rate than you know
other countries but i don't think that
that's part of my definition of
liberalism so it really does have to do
with that foundation of
respect for law and respect for limits
uh to government uh power yeah and that
that idea that you can
you know essentially you can be in a
liberal society and
provided it's electorally
endorsed
you can
you know draw the line economically on
the size of the state wherever you like
i mean you do draw a distinction quite
early in the book between
liberalism and democracy and we talk
about liberal democracy in a single
breath right but you do draw an
analytic distinction between those two
things don't you you know i think that's
necessary i think that liberalism and
democracy have been allies for much of
the last you know 100 years but they're
not the same thing
so you could have a democratically
elected government that doesn't respect
liberal limitations on power
and i'm afraid you know that's really
what's going on in hungary right now
where victor orban
is legitimately elected but he's used
that
mandate that electoral mandate to
basically corral the media you know turn
over uh uh properties and and control of
a lot of the economy to cronies of his
and he's
explicitly endorsed you know what he
calls illiberal democracy where you're
not going to respect the rights of
individuals uh to the extent same extent
as other truly liberal countries in the
rest of europe and he does that with a
certain democratic
mandate and i think this is true of a
lot of right-wing
populists these days you know from
erdogan and turkey to donald trump in
the united states they all do get
elected democratically but they are not
you know respecters of
liberal limitations on uh their own
power but is that i mean would you
characterize that as a and
i mean
would you characterize that as a
democracy
that's continuing to be a democracy
that's illiberal or
is it essentially you know once we've
got the power through democratic means
and we're rolling back the foundation
well i mean can a liberal democracy be
stable or is it essentially a
contradiction i i don't think it can be
stable over the long run because
the first thing that these illiberal
democrats do is to try to change the
electoral laws
so that they will never be removed from
power so orban has done that in hungary
he's done a lot of gerrymandering of
electoral districts to make sure that
his fidez party
really has a a big advantage despite
whatever the popular vote may say and
it's been going on in the united states
i think the republicans at a state level
have been changing the
rules actually the the rules for
counting votes such that you know if we
have a closely contested election in
2024 they would actually be able to
override popular will because they would
award the right to assign you know we've
got this very
strange system in the united states
where we don't elect presidents by
popular vote we we have this electoral
college and they want to be able to
control that so that yes they will be
able to
override democratic choice in the future
so i do think that there's a good reason
why liberalism and democracy are closely
allied with one another i think that if
you only have democracy
uh it tends to erode liberalism and then
that tends to erode uh you know
democracy itself yeah
now this
idea of erosion is kind of fundamental
to the book i think because the book is
sort of saying where we're going wrong
or where liberalism is under threat and
you see it as i understand it it's
threatened both on the left and the
right
as you see it but are those those
threats symmetrical and are those
threats effectively arising from the
same conception of liberalism are they
um
i i think that they come from uh
different sources but they are
feeding off of one another and so
uh as people push the boundaries of
liberalism you know to uh
extreme on the right or the left it
stimulates the other side you know to
push in a similar
direction but the the problems are
really different so i think on the right
uh really what happened was the
uh expansion of the notion of liberalism
uh during the 1980s and 90s to something
that's now called neo-liberalism
sometimes neoliberalism is just a
synonym for capitalism but i think that
you know more accurately
it was a um kind of ideology that
worshipped markets and denigrated the
state to the point that it began to
erode a lot of state institutions and
led to a a kind of globalization that
looked at economic efficiency as the be
all and end-all of you know of life and
that began to erode people's incomes it
permitted you know the growth of a great
deal of uh inequality uh across the
world
uh it eroded the state's ability to
regulate the activities of you know
large corporations and especially in the
financial sector
i think was directly responsible for the
uh the big financial crisis in 2008
because
you know the deregulation of that sector
permitted these big banks to take you
know unconscionable risks and it hurt
ordinary people and so
this uh was a development on the right
that then stimulated the growth of the
left because
people looked at this and they said this
is you know unacceptable that we get
this degree of inequality
and that's really what launched you know
the progressivism that you now see
across the developed world although the
progressivism that that you're
specifically
concerned about in this book isn't
if i'm kind of paraphrasing you right
isn't the economical economic one right
but an identitarian one i mean the sort
of backlash against neoliberalism
globally could be seen as almost kind of
traditional marxist yeah so i'm actually
i i'm all in favor of a lot of
traditional social democratic policies i
actually think that
especially in the united states
we need more redistribution uh because i
think that liberalism
needs to be tempered by democracy that
is to say by
some equalization of outcomes because
liberalism by itself produces too much
inequality so i'm i'm so is that we've
got illiberal democracies but there's
also the anti-democratic liberalism
that's right that's right um
uh
so that's fine uh i think however that
you know what what what's defined the
left has shifted a lot and it's shifted
for understandable reasons
uh not to be based on these broad
categories like social class as karl
marx had it you know the bourgeoisie and
the proletariat but to see inequality in
terms of the specific injustices
done to racial minorities to immigrants
to women to
gays and lesbians to transgender people
and so in a sense the
understanding that inequality has
shifted and
you know i
want to be understood here you know this
was understandable and and it was a
necessary shift in the understanding of
inequality because there is there are
different forms of marginalization that
take place in liberal societies and
those specific abuses needed to be
dealt with but
it also had consequences in in the way
that people thought about the society
and ended up becoming a general critique
of liberalism and the liberal
individualism that kind of underlies you
know
liberal thought and that's really i
think where the problem comes up and is
your position that within the ambit of
trad capital liberalism it is possible
to produce redresses for the injustices
you describe
without if you like
you know removing that
idea of individualism that that's
central to no of course i mean anyone
that thinks that liberal societies
haven't reformed themselves in really
major ways
over the last you know 150 years just
hasn't been paying attention i mean we
had slavery in the united states you
know and
for all that in in the u.s uh there are
still huge disparities and outcomes for
african-americans uh versus white
americans
uh there's no question that there's been
a tremendous amount of you know of
economic and social advance
and it's not a complete process but that
doesn't i think speak to the core of
liberalism that still
maintains that there's a human essence
that needs to be protected by rights and
needs to be protected you know
regardless of the racial gender you know
sexual orientation of the individual
involved yeah now you mentioned human
essence and that you know to go right
back down to the beginning of liberalism
you discuss you know [ __ ] and and later
rules as a sort of epic can
um
which
you know posits some quite sort of
theoretical our priority abstract
underpinnings for
liberalism absolutely but
you know and it is a sort of very
universalist creed i think you'd agree
but
you know as you also put out you know it
does have a very historically specific
origin yes you know there's 150 years of
religious war in western europe
is it something that can
transcend that origin and become as
abstract as and as universal as we think
it is or is it you know because i think
one of the critiques of liberalism
sometimes made is it's very you know
specific to the west it's very right you
know it can't escape its historical
origins
no that's uh that's true i think that in
fact it goes
even back further uh beyond those wars
of religion into
something that's very deep within the
judeo-christian tradition
you know in the book of genesis
adam and eve are expelled from the
garden of eden because
they make the wrong choice they eat the
the forbidden fruit and i think that
that story embeds a certain notion of
human agency that human beings have the
power to decide between good and evil
and that moral autonomy is really the
basis of a liberal understanding i mean
that's really what holds the human race
together is that ability to make choices
between
right and wrong and the specific
definition of right and wrong may vary
culturally but that's something that
you know in liberal theory all human
beings have
and as
the centuries roll by that gets expanded
into our current you know democratic
understanding of
human universality that all people have
a right to make basic choices in their
lives you know
where they live how they should live uh
who they're going to marry
what kind of occupations they'll follow
and it you know eventually comes to
entail things like a right to vote
because you also
should have a right to equal political
power at least equal access to the
political system so yes it is um
something that's historically
nurtured in western thought it goes back
a very very long ways
but the question i think is really
is it something that actually only
people that grow up in that cultural
tradition
prize or is it something that actually a
lot of other people from other cultural
traditions may
partake in and i think you know the
experience of
the spread of these ideas outside of the
west indicates that yeah there is maybe
something you know truly merciful right
yeah
um
now
again one
among the critiques of liberalism
and it's one that i think you seem to
compass in this book is that
it's very good as something to be said
for democracy more for what it prevents
than from what it enables and the two
two planks again i correct me if i'm
misunderstanding you of the difficulty
of liberalism is that it doesn't
it has a very good way of arbitrating
between competing notions of the good
but it's not very good at coming up with
a notion of the good in nor itself right
and the second one is that it has
trouble dealing with
nations and those you know the sort of
essential social human groupings in
which it
it works is it
are those systemic problems with
liberalism and i mean
it sort of begs the question is
liberalism enough if it won't account
for those two
no that's that's absolutely correct so
the essence of liberalism is to say look
uh we cannot agree on the good life as
defined let's say by a religious
tradition uh if we insist that our
politics should be built around a single
religion
we're going to end up fighting each
other as europe did you know after the
protestant reformation and so we're
going to lower the sites of politics to
say that we want to survive
live peacefully among
one another and agree to disagree about
those ultimate
things and that means that you're not
going to get a tightly bound religious
community of the sort you know of let's
say john calvin's geneva
but that's that's not a that's not a bug
that's a future of liberalism but it
does mean that if you want a strong
sense of community you're probably not
going to get it in a liberal society i
think that
the um attraction that people have to
feel about liberal societies
really has to do more with freedom and
the ability to
you know make uh what you want of your
own life you know this ability not to be
told by either your your your priest or
the government you know how how you
ought to live and that's something that
people
uh can take pride in the second issue
you mentioned really does have to do
with the nation uh and i think that is
also a problem because liberals believe
that all human beings have equal rights
and that those rights need to be
protected
by governments
i think that you can actually reconcile
liberal theory with the actual existence
of nations because
those rights need to be protected
uh you know by actually a state
you know state is really the
locus of power in the modern world and
states necessarily have limits on whose
rights they can protect
and so if you live in a liberal society
it has an obligation to protect the
rights of the citizens of that society
also people living in the society that
are not citizens
uh have rights as well at a slightly
lower level than than actual citizens
who have the right to vote and and so
forth
but
you know the way the world is organized
that state does not have the
obligation to protect the rights in
countries you know a thousand miles away
and in fact if they try to do that
that's also going to lead to a pretty
chaotic world where states are able to
use force you know way outside of their
territorial jurisdictions
so that's why i think uh the nation and
liberal theory you know
need to come together the other thing is
that
in a liberal society uh people need to
have a source of community and and
mutual identification and the nation
still remains a pretty strong source of
that and you just go to an olympics and
watch people
you know cheering for their own uh for
their own country
and i think that you know that's an
important identification that needs to
be kept liberal meaning to say
you can't build a nation
around race around religion around some
fixed
um
uh value but it can
well you can yeah and that's been the
source of problems right so
that's really what we're facing in
contemporary russia that they've got
this one-night you know notion of what
russian national identity is that's not
compatible with you know multiple
other ethnic identities within their own
you know within their own society
so um
so it's a you know it's an uneasy
uh
uh
compromise in a sense you know between
liberal
ideals of universal you know human
equality and the need for nations but i
think it's one that can actually be
reconciled in practice
can
um
i'm wondering how much the
that idea that there is a sort of um
communitarian underpinning to the
liberal
dispensation in any given nation state
how that's been affected whether
undermined or
you know improved by
globalization i mean in the sense that
you know
when you've been talking about
neoliberalism and the difficulties of of
you know allowing inequality to run
right it's it's much harder to create i
guess a juridical framework in which
you know inequality can be reined in by
the democratic process by you know
anti-trust laws and so on when you've
got
capital and
for that matter the the companies that
run it are so international they're
outside the reach of any given states
laws i mean is that not
something that causes you to no sure no
that's it has been a big problem that
uh because the globalization
uh brought about by
you know what i would call neoliberal
ideology has put economic efficiency
at the summit of all social goods uh it
necessarily erodes other
uh objectives that a democratic
community may you know want to pursue so
this is clearest in in terms of
environment where a lot of the global
trade laws have actually gotten in the
way of environmental enforcement because
you know according to the
uh the free traders you know these are
simply
uh political obstacles that are meant to
be protectionist rather than you know
serving other ends and i don't think
that that's an acceptable understanding
of the way democratic communities have a
right to
you know determine their own futures so
you know economic efficiency should be
one social good
among you know others and it really
ought to be up to democratic communities
to
determine the priority the relative
priority let's say of environmental
protection against economic efficiency
and how i mean obviously
democratic communities can make those
decisions but when the problems are
global when the money moves globally
it's much harder for them to do that
how much sort of
stock do you play do you place in the
international institutions which i guess
are our best attempt to to regulate
those problems of the u.n
military alliances the eu so forth i
mean well um there's such a variety of
international institutions that it's
impossible to generalize
i think the united nations has been a
failure in terms of regulating security
just because of the nature of the
security council that whenever you get a
dispute between one of those five two of
those five members you you don't get any
kind of action
uh whatsoever and i think that's been
repeatedly demonstrated on the other
hand you know there are other areas like
public health where the world health
organization
actually plays a pretty important role
in
coordinating responses to things like
global pandemics you know
it it didn't do an adequate job during
covid but it's much better that it
existed than it doesn't and then the
bretton woods institutions the world
bank and the imf you know also play
important roles in regulating
you know a lot of um
our economic lives and especially the
lives of of you know poorer countries
uh so it really depends you know in the
security realm
nato i think is really an important
institution uh worked during the cold
war and i think it's working today
in
in light of the the challenge posed by
russia but
i think that
you know especially global warming has
led a lot of people to say that
you know the entire
universe of existing institutions
because they are based on nation states
will not be adequate
uh to meet the challenges
and needs to be replaced by something
more resembling global government
and that i think is is a dangerous idea
because
at a nation-state level
we have developed institutions that
balance
the power of the state with instruments
of constraint that's what the rule of
law is it basically says
if you have executive authority there
are certain things you cannot do to
violate individual rights or to
act against commonly accepted laws and
they have to be democratically
they have to be democratically
legitimated and anybody that says that
we need to replace the existing
nation-state-based type of cooperation
with some form of global governance
really has to explain how you would
limit the actions of a global executive
you know through law or through um
uh you know democratic legitimacy and we
have no idea how to do this
you know the idea that the united states
and china and europe can all agree on
you know a common set of
laws and rules and then delegate serious
coercive uh power to this organization i
you just try to imagine that and
you realize why that's not going to
happen also i suppose as you've you know
we've seen again and again
you know material liberal democracies
kind of have to be rooted in a set of
customs and conditions and
structures um
you know a lot of the conversations
we've been having
you know in the media as has been saying
that this is
you know a crunch point this is the
front line of the war of liberalism
against
tyranny or autocracy i'm wondering
do you think that's
that's right without qualification i
mean do you see the the ukrainians
essentially as fighting on behalf
of an idea or or are they fighting for
thumbs are they fighting for
a nationalism or a sense of their
homeland
well look it it's uh it's a little bit
of both uh i actually
have been uh spending a lot of time in
ukraine over the last seven eight years
and have lots of
ukrainian friends and you know they're
doing it out of i mean nobody does one
or the other everybody
fights for their independence and
sovereignty even if you don't live in a
democracy
but in ukraine i do think that people
have appreciated the fact that they're
living in a free society they can
criticize the government they can say
what they want and they want to defend
that right and they don't want putin to
take it away from them
and so you know what they're doing is is
a combination both of you know patriotic
defense of their sovereignty and it's a
fight for you know higher ideals and i
think that to the extent that
you know it's a mixture of the both that
all of us have an interest in in
supporting that because
you know that broader liberal democratic
order is really i think what's at stake
in this in this current war it's not a
war just about this country ukraine it's
it's really
the attempt to roll back the entire
expansion of the realm of liberal
democracy that took place after 1991 and
the collapse of the of the former soviet
union
yeah
parenthetically you do mention ukraine
in the book and you say because you've
obviously been working in ukraine with
um you know scholars of liberalism and
democratic institutions you said that
it's it's got the it has or had before
the invasion the most complete sort of
oligarchic control of the media
or anywhere in the world which is very
surprising to me because i mean
certainly you know having paid attention
to ukraine more more recently and the
impression it was this extraordinarily
pluralistic liberal democracy
no that's uh that's true i mean the big
problem in in ukraine prior to the war
was corruption and the corruption came
from the fact that much of the economy
was owned by you know six or seven
oligarchs that were a kind of byproduct
of the way the soviet union collapsed
what's remarkable
is that
that structure has really crumbled now
and
ukraine has experienced a kind of birth
of a nation
that really would not have been possible
but for the invasion so the oligarchs
have all fled uh their properties are
being confiscated or destroyed
confiscated by the russians confiscated
by the russians
right okay uh you know like renat
akmyatov who is the big kind of
pro-russian oligarch in eastern ukraine
just had his largest steel factory
bombed by the russians
uh and so russian yeah he was he tended
to be pro-russian you know before the uh
before the invasion
none of the russian speakers as far as i
can see have any sympathy now for russia
given what they've done in kharkiv and
other you know russian speaking uh these
areas generally russia russian speakers
no no no no no no they were divided i
mean some were based in eastern ukraine
some in western ukraine so there was a
variety but
but i think that that whole
earlier division has really been
replaced by an extraordinary sense of
national
unity
around zalensky and around the idea of a
you know of a free ukraine
uh so
you know vladimir putin is i think going
to be remembered as one of the fathers
of the ukrainian nation you know
you know over with
and
zielinski who you know most of us have
come to consciousness of
as a you know a sort of
war hero president you know um how
did you rate him before all this
happened i mean you will see someone who
understands ukrainian politics
pretty well was he deeply implicated
with these oligarchs was he ruling about
omission of them uh
to a much less extent than other
ukrainian politicians
he had been linked at the time of his
election to kolomoisky who was one of
the oligarchs
who owned the tv station where
zielenski's show servant of the people
originally aired and there had been a
lot of you know suspicion that he was
acting on kolomoisky's
behalf i think that after he became
elected
he proved that that actually wasn't true
you know they continued to act against
kolomoisky's interest
there was a big bank you know reversal
of privatization that they were trying
to contest and he didn't manage to do
that
uh and i think that you know the thing
that was remarkable about zelensky was
that he was the outsider candidate
that was elected over
other candidates that were much more
representative of oligarchic interests
by an incredible margin which indicated
that you know the ukrainian people as a
whole really wanted an outsider that
wasn't connected to any of the existing
corrupt elite
what happened after he was elected was
that those same oligarchs then tried to
corrupt you know the parliamentarians in
his own party and so there's a
continuing struggle but i think to a
much greater extent than previous
politicians uh you know zelinski was
free of that kind of oligarchic control
so his being elected in the first place
would be you'd say an instance of
liberalism and the rule of law
absolutely and democracy and something
that would be completely impossible in
russia for example
francis fukuyama thank you very much
thank you for talking to me
you